bonjour et bienvenue pour le journal de
la rédaction pour une nouvelle édition
du 7/8 dorénavant sur tvfilm l'actualité
et c'est du lundi au vendredi bienvenue
voici les principaux titres que nous
allons développer en ceci septembre elle
a rentré scolaire c'était cette semaine
dans le département a été plutôt calme
nous allons revenir sur ses premiers
jours d'école et sur la mise en place
dans certaines villes du nouveau rythme
scolaire avec sur ce plateau le
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale des Yvelines les
violences s'attrapent sont-elles
oubliées l'été a été agité dans d'autres
communes également les mers ont alerté
les pouvoirs publics aujourd'hui quelle
est la situation nous tentons d'apporter
quelques éléments de réponse
et puis la National 10 couvertant en
2018 à Trappes l'enfouissement de cette
route qui voit passer chaque jour 80 000
véhicules étant passe d’être lancé
l'état vient de donner un coup de pouce
financier de plusieurs millions d'euros
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
et l'image du joueur la voici c'est la
toute nouvelle résidence étudiante René
Cassin à Élancourt inauguré ce matin
même en présence des élus locaux plus de
160 logements 161 très précisément situé
juste au-dessus de la mairie le site a
été complètement rénové une réalisation
qui devrait soulager un peu la pénurie
actuelle de solutions d'hébergement pour
les étudiants sur le secteur
l'invité qui nous accompagnera donc tout
au long de cette édition c'est
Jean-Michel Coignières bonsoir bienvenue
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale des Yvelines
j'évoquais en titre une rentrée scolaire
qui s'est finalement plutôt bien passé
est-ce que c'est le cas visiblement il y
a eu moins de mobilisation que les
années passées si on accepte la ville de
Sartrouville mobilisation pour une
ouverture de classe en maternelle oui
qu'on a pu arbitrer très peu de temps
après la rentrée donc en effet beaucoup
de calme ce qui correspondait bien à
l'environnement bien ensoleillé que nous
donnait la météo on rentrait sous le
soleil dans le calme comment ça
s'explique à la rentrée ce soir aussi
calme il y a eu plus de poste
on a plus de poste on se trompe pas trop
sur les prévisions d'effectif même si là
on a on assistait une poussée je sais
pas si on y reviendra mais le
département est positif en démographie
mais sur les petits on voit qu'on a
davantage et puis on a trouvé une
méthode avec les mers les inspecteurs
les directeurs d'école les représentants
des personnels tels que on n'attend pas
de compter après la rentrée mais dès que
l'on a l'assurance de chiffres on met le
moyen le déterminer tout de suite les
postes tout de suite on a commencé le 30
août comme ça pour qu'un maximum
d'écoles et leur nombre de classes pour
l'année dès la rentrée on va parler donc
de cette rentrée scolaire direction La
Verrière comment s'est passé la rentrée
dans cette commune plus particulièrement
pour les élèves de Nicolas Perrier c'est
un jeune enseignant de l'école du bois
de l'étang le reportage d'Anthony Rey
chez d'élody moi
pour l'instant sa classe est vide et
silencieuses Nicolas a juste son plan de
table et pose les carnets de liaison de
ses futurs élèves pour sa première
rentrée scolaire ce jeune professeur des
écoles stagiaires est impatient de
découvrir sa classe de CE1 pour une
première journée prise de contact
beaucoup de choses administratives la
préparation des cahiers faire des choses
comme ça après on va expliquer aussi ce
qu'on va faire pendant l'année commencer
certains petits rituels qu'on fera tout
au long de l'année comme parler du temps
de la date des choses comme ça
arrivait dans la cour d'école les
enfants veulent à tout prix savoir dans
quelle classe ils seront tout le monde
scrute les listes pour savoir si les
copains de l'année dernière seront là et
tu vas être dans quelle classe alors CE2
et tu vas retrouver tes copines
tu es content d'aller à l'école le
cartable il est prêt
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
mais pour certains quitter maman pour
rentrer en classe se fait à recul
très seul très sale on est nouveau ici
donc
on attend désespérément de se faire des
copines alors les CE1 on fait un beau
rang de par deux s'il vous plaît
une fois ces 23 élèves installés Nicolas
délivre ses premières consignes tous les
jours on fera de la lecture
c'est reparti pour une nouvelle année de
découverte et d'apprentissage
quelques chiffres pour cette rentrée
30067 élèves Yves Linois sont retournés
à l'école cette semaine dans le premier
le second degré publique et privé
confondu côté enseignant 74 créations de
postes dans le premier degré une
centaine dans le second au total combien
de professeurs sur ce département des
Yvelines
il y avait professeur d'un côté mais si
on regarde les adultes qu'ils ont cadres
les professeurs les personnes
administratifs les personnels municipaux
pour les écoles les Atos du conseil
général on peut dire qu'on est à quasi
30000 adultes qui au quotidien travaille
auprès des enfants si on regarde un peu
ce qui se passe dans la raison c'est de
l'ordre de 18000 si on regarde un peu ce
qui se passe dans le reste du
département le département des Yvelines
dans les autres départements je veux
dire dans le département des Yvelines
c'est là où il y a le plus d'enseignants
parce que c'est là qu'il y a le plus
d'élèves aussi oui c'est le plus gros
département de l'académie de Versailles
mais on voit que la pression
démographique est donc le nombre de
postes d'enseignants augmente notamment
les Hauts-de-Seine qui se rapprochent de
nous et puis un degré un peu moins de le
Val-d'Oise on peut s'attendre à une
poussée démographique sur les quelques
années encore on va avoir une poussée
démographique c'est l'occasion pour moi
de dire que d'une part il y a une
poussée interne c'est à dire que
davantage d'enfants et c'est un bien
pour suivre leurs études plus vite donc
notamment le passage en seconde explose
on voit que par le haut les résultats au
bac sont très bons donc on a aussi en
craie du BTS et de l'étudiant et puis
d'autre part on a un facteur externe qui
nous touche tous vous voyez le long de
la scène à partir de Hauts-de-Seine tout
le nord du département et puis jusqu'au
Val-d'Oise une poussée avec la
redynamisation
urbaine dans certains endroits des
familles nous arrivent nouvelles et
alors la particularité cette année comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est
qu'elle arrive au premier enfant elle
nous scolarise en maternelle aujourd'hui
c'est suffisant le nombre d'enseignants
pour encadrer
la semaine dernière 290 professeurs des
écoles entamé leur première rentrée
scolaire dans le département à
Marly-le-Roi une journée d'accueil était
organisée échange avec le Directeur
Académique découverte du calendrier de
l'année et conseille administratif
Christelle a de la chance elle connaît
son affectation depuis juillet et a pu
se préparer mais elle appréhende tout de
même le premier jour de classe un
patiente de découvrir la classe de de
voir l'école une première rentrée
comment ça se passe mais aussi stressée
parce que je sais pas comment ça va se
passer comment gérer les élèves leurs
difficultés l'année prochaine les jeunes
enseignants connaîtront une autre
formation ici la plupart ont tenté les
cours sans jamais avoir connu le face à
face avec des élèves heureusement
christelle est une des rares professeurs
à avoir profité d'une formation en
alternance elle s'est donc déjà frottée
à des écoliers et des journées de
formation sont encore au programme pour
cette année
à la veille de la reprise nous la
retrouvons pour la pré-entrée au sein de
son nouvel établissement l'école Jean
Macé à Trappes
voilà classe de CM1 pour l'instant avec
personne aucun élève
ce qu'ils arriveront demain une salle
bien vide qu'elle a commencé à aménager
aujourd'hui installation des tables et
affichage du programme reste un souci
majeur à J-1 les fournitures scolaires
ne sont toujours pas arrivés
j'ai aucun matériel aucun cahier aucun
stylo donc j'espère que les élèves
auront tous en matériel demain autre
point où il faudra s'adapter l'école de
Christelle mettent en place la réforme
des rythmes scolaires on va travailler 4
jours et demi et les horaires changent
aussi donc il va falloir que je le
rappelle demain aux élèves parce que je
pense qu'il y en a qui vont être un
petit peu perdu c'est la pause du midi
Christelle rejoint ses collègues dans la
salle des professeurs pour une grande
paella ici ça prouve que l'équipe est
quand même soudée qui travaille ensemble
donc c'est agréable de quoi bien débuter
l'année avant le baptême du feu demain
ce baptême du feu cet enseignante là
donc déjà vécu 290 p.e.s professeur des
écoles stagiaires c'est 45 de plus que
l'an passé qu'est-ce qui explique cette
hausse d'une part on a eu plus de poste
donc il faut bien les pourvoirs et puis
d'autre part on a une année charnière où
on a deux concours
et donc pour la part de prof d'école
stagiaire ancien modèle finalement on a
pu l'augmenter un peu tout en préservant
la possibilité d'accueillir 253 je crois
à ce jour étudiant qui assume une partie
c'est la nouvelle version c'est la
nouvelle version nouvelle version du
concours
en même temps à la sortie l'année
prochaine comme nouveau stagiaire mais
les stagiaires qui seront très
différents puisqu'ils auront exercés à
tiers toute l'année au total vous voyez
ça fait 530 nouveaux enseignants d'une
façon ou d'une autre dans le département
de version d'entrée dans la profession
l'ancienne version la nouvelle avec
l'ouverture de l'école supérieure du
professeur de l'éducation dans lequel
relève ceci les 252
évidemment ça fait de la masse et nous
on met notre tout notre cœur à les
accompagner elle commence à le dire dans
le reportage donc il y a des
regroupements de ces jeunes des
formations perlées toute l'année afin
que leur première année pour les PES se
passent bien et afin pour les autres que
leurs études et la préparation à
l'admissibilité à la mission du concours
soit les meilleurs possibles cette école
supérieure du professorat de l'éducation
ESPE ça remplace les ufm ça fonctionne
sur le même format même formule non on
peut pas comparer la seule comparaison
c'est qu'on a une école pour toute une
académie pour former tous les personnels
d'enseignement donc enseignants mais
aussi CPE par exemple là ça va être la
comparaison puisque pour les grands
principes qui régissent le
fonctionnement de ces formations et ils
sont totalement modifiés et puisque
surtout nous allons avoir un rôle c'est
à dire l'enseignement scolaire les
inspecteurs les maths formateurs à
l'intérieur de ces écoles en vue
d'améliorer la professionnalisation de
ces de ces la grande nouveauté cette
année c'est cette réforme scolaire qu'on
évoque à peu près depuis le début de
cette édition mais on va vraiment s'y
pencher à présent nous étions attrape on
va y rester c'est l'une des communes qui
s'est lancée dans cette réforme des
cette année quatre jours et demi de
cours pour les élèves le mercredi matin
dorénavant il faut aller à l'école trap
fait partie de ces communes il y en a 9
en tout Poissy Vélizy même qui s'était
lancé un petit peu avant dans cette dans
cet aventure là dans cette réforme sur
262 communes dans le département c'est
finalement assez peu seulement 9 qui ont
sauté le pas des cette année c'est peu
en effet mais les communes avaient le
choix de reporter ou non à 2014 en même
temps ça fait un panel intéressant pour
nous puisque ça représente quand même 9
% des élèves quand on regarde par cet
entrée là et puis un panel de taille de
commune il y a des communes importantes
que vous avez cités puis ensuite des
communes plus petites ou évidemment la
façon de faire va être très différente
vous avez prévenu déjà les maires des
autres communes il va falloir se
détailler
pour l'organisation pour eux au moins
pour les horaires scolaires il faudrait
que la réflexion c'est dans les autres
communes avance rapidement et que en
réalité avant Noël on puisse statuer je
puisse statuer sur leurs horaires de
l'an prochain pourquoi ce délai court
finalement on rentre en septembre
simplement on a l'expérience de l'an
dernier les concertations avaient déjà
commencé et on sait mieux comment dire
ce qu'on est dans le temps les
différentes étapes on peut penser que
par exemple en premier lieu ce qui avait
fait beaucoup des balles en dernier
le problème mercredi ou samedi et
quelque chose qui peut faire l'objet
rapidement dans une commune d'un choix
voilà une fois que celui-là est fait on
a appris avec les communes qui ont
accompli tout le chemin qu'ensuite il
fallait se déterminer sur finalement les
jours scolaires hors mercredi matin ça
c'est pas non plus très compliqué ça se
discute et donc on réserverait j'abrège
au réserverait la partie élaboration du
projet éducatif territorial c'est à dire
la nature des activités leur
complémentarité à l'école pour jusqu'au
mois de juin donc il me semble que pour
descendre on doit pouvoir à peu près
dans chaque commune voir se dessiner
l'organisation horaire de la semaine
boucler ce dossier là pour les
municipalités avant la fin de l'année
2013 c'est aussi pour éviter les
discussions qui risquent de s'éterniser
pendant la campagne électorale pour les
municipales ça peut être un enjeu de
campagne aussi par ailleurs voilà il y a
un agenda chargé cette année dans les
dans les communes
autant avoir déjà délibéré cela alors
qu'on a un an derrière nous plutôt que
de se retrouver comme pour les communes
qui se lancent cette année en toute fin
d'année avril mai juin à essayer de
boucler quelque chose alors que les
esprits sont pas vraiment réceptifs
alors que pensent les parents de la mise
en place de cette réforme voici un
micro-trottoir réalisé attrape à la
sortie de l'école
très mal c'est super mal fait l'école
mercredi c'est pas évident pour les
parents qui travaillent comme nous
l'école le matin à 8h50 c'est pas
possible ça le maire il voit pas que on
peut pas on peut pas déposer nos offres
à 8h50 et les récupérer à 4h15 nous en
travaux on fait comment c'est vrai que
le mercredi pour 2h30 c'est pénible un
petit peu mais bon on n'a pas le choix
et pour l'instant ça a pas l'air de
poser problème il faut s'y adapter ça a
été prévu si adapté je peux pas vous
donner encore d'impression réelle mais
c'est vrai que ça a nécessité de
s'organiser
différemment par rapport aux années
précédentes il faut s'habituer parce que
les rythmes sont nouveaux je crois qu'on
peut pas être en parler parce que c'est
le premier jour on verra à la fin de
l'année on le verra on fera le point on
verra si les enfants sont plus reposer
et s'ils sont plus épanouis donc on
verra ça en fin d'année mais je reste
sceptique
des parents forcément qui sont encore
sceptiques est-ce qu'il y aura un bilan
d'étape qui va être fait dans les
communes qui se sont déjà lancées oui on
va continuer ce que nous avons mis en
place il y a un comité de suivi
au niveau départemental donc déjà l'an
dernier les 8 communes avaient bien
voulu présenter leurs difficultés mais
aussi leur choix donc on va continuer on
se réunit le 19 septembre on va faire un
petit bilan de rentrée comme on le dit
dans le reportage il va y avoir deux
choses c'est d'une part la mise en place
matérielle concrète comme le disait les
mamans là il faut sans doute attendre
les vacances de Toussaint pour voir si
c'est régulier si chaque famille a
trouvé son organisation puis un autre
bilan un peu plus un peu plus sérieux
c'était évoqué aussi c'est est-ce que
c'est un impact sur la vie des enfants
parce que le but faut pas l'oublier de
la référence c'est qu'on étale mieux les
temps scolaires en tout cas dans la
semaine donc ça faudra qu'on le mesure
au fil de trimestre
et on aura l'occasion d'y revenir en
cours d'année vous serez le bienvenu sur
ce plateau pour commenter un peu cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires cette
année et celle de la refondation de
l'école c'est le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Vincent payant qui le dit et
il y a une priorité qui est donnée au
primaire avec plus de mètres que de
classe par exemple ou encore une
scolarisation des moins de 3 ans pour
conclure on peut peut-être s'intéresser
à ces différents c'est de quelle manière
se traduit cette priorité donnée à
l'école primaire dans le cadre de la
refondation dans les Yvelines ça se
traduit par déjà un certain nombre de
postes et donc de projet on en a 31 pour
le dispositif plus de maître que de
classe et puis 13 pour les dispositifs
moins de 3 ans
ça concerne avant tout des quartiers des
villes dans lesquelles la compensation
scolaire doit être plus forte c'est un
point qu'il faut souligner donc on a
installé ces dispositifs avec des
maîtres volontaires dans des quartiers
où la difficulté la plus grande et le
deuxième très peut-être c'est de dire
qu'on est on a été très exigeant sur le
montage de ces dispositifs
je vais évoquer juste celui des moins de
3 ans il s'agit pas de généraliser la
scolarisation des deux ans il s'agit à
partir d'un cahier des charges que les
maires eux-mêmes cosignent de faire bloc
et d'aller chercher des familles qui
nous auraient pas confié leur enfant à
partir de leur mort leur mode de garde
de petite enfance soit dans la famille
ou dans la crèche avec certaines
communes dont la ville de Trappes
notamment absolument pour faciliter ça
on compte là dessus pour offrir un temps
scolaire plus long finalement entre
guillemets sur la carrière scolaire de
façon à mieux faire rentrer dans les
apprentissages donc on rencontre
beaucoup enfin moi dans les départements
je compte beaucoup sur le ce qu'on
dévaluera de ce dispositif Jean-Michel
Coignard directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale dans
le département je vous propose de rester
encore quelques instants avec nous on va
quitter l'école primaire pour
l'enseignement supérieur et cette
problématique du logement pour les
étudiants une nouvelle résidence
résidence flambant neuve a été inaugurée
à ce vendredi à Élancourt ici vous allez
le voir se trouver l'immeuble de bureau
le Capitole des bureaux transformés en
161 log ements de 16 à 27 mètres carrés
réservé à des étudiants en majorité
boursiers pour un loyer compris entre
220 et 230 euros des logements bien
équipés dotés d'une petite chaînette
d'une salle de bain une résidence gérée
par le CROUS qui en ce mois de septembre
vient d'inaugurer aussi dans les
Yvelines et dans les Hauts-de-Seine pas
moins de 6 nouvelles résidences on
écouta ce sujet la directrice du CROUS
Françoise beer
c'est 161 logements donc à Élancourt qui
complète l'offre du CROUS sur la ville
d'Élancourt puisque nous irons déjà sans
dilogements très à proximité et ensuite
nous ouvrons donc en parallèle plus sur
le site de Versailles pour répondre aux
besoins de l'Université des écoles de
résidence à Versailles donc qui seront
inaugurés la semaine prochaine donc deux
petites résidences pour une 110 lire au
total et une résidence à Viroflay
165 chambres donc là c'est le fruit d'un
travail en amont et nous avons
éventuellement d'autres projets bien
évidemment pour répondre aux besoins des
étudiants sur le secteur le 7 8 Actu du
vendredi se poursuit si vous venez de
nous rejoindre nous revenons sur
l'actualité du jour mais aussi sur les
principaux faits de l'actualité de la
semaine et l'on s'intéresse à présent à
ce climat particulier qui s'est installé
dans plusieurs communes entre crises de
la citoyenneté et islamophobie vous avez
suivi ces émeutes à Trappes déclenchés
par un contrôle d'identité d'une jeune
femme voilée et ensuite dégénéré puis la
plante déposée dans cette même ville par
une autre femme voilée qui dit avoir été
agressée pour ses croyances religieuses
alors qu'on revoit ces images de ses
émeutes au mois de mois de juillet on va
écouter l'imam Youssef bawendi le prêche
à trappe voici ce qu'il pense sur la
question de l'islamophobie
l'islamophobie c'est un phénomène qui
existe il ne faut pas le négliger suffit
simplement de
voir avec l'Observatoire le nombre
d'agressions étant net augmentation les
musulmans sont des citoyens apparentiels
ils ne sont pas moins nombreux que les
homosexuels sont pas moins nombreux que
les Juifs et il faut les respecter il
faut que la loi les protège parce que
agresser un citoyen quel que soit sa
couleur ou son audience que ce soit
religieuse ou ethnique est un acte
raciste attrape moi je sais que le
commissaire est un homme sage
intelligent
je lui demande simplement de rappeler
ces hommes un peu à l'ordre au respect
du citoyen quel que soit le citoyen même
s'il est vraiment un voyou de ne pas de
répondre aussi à la provocation c'est
vrai que les jeunes parfois ont tendance
à provoquer la police il ne faut pas que
la police tombe dans ce piège là et il
suffit simplement quand provoque au
contraire des réunions entre policiers
et citoyens et essayer de désamorcer ce
climat qui est un peu tendu aujourd'hui
pour revenir quand même une vie calme et
une ville calme aussi Jean-Michel
Coignières le directeur académique des
services de l'éducation nationale dans
le département merci d'être resté sur ce
plateau je voulais vous faire réagir sur
ce climat ses incivilités qu'on retrouve
sans évoquer la question de
l'islamophobie j'aimerais tout de même
savoir comment vous intervenez dans dans
les écoles peut-être pour les plus
jeunes aussi pour leur apprendre à
respecter tout simplement être citoyen
aussi voulu absolument je crois que
c'est vraiment un problème d'éducation à
la citoyenneté nous sommes très très
vigilants dans certains quartiers des
villes particulièrement à Trappes et
nous essayons d'unifier notre action de
prévention
l'éducation la citoyenneté par exemple
sur trappe c'est très clair on va
unifier cette année les politiques des
collèges et des lycées de manière à
graduellement offrir des conditions aux
jeunes qu'on accueille parce qu'on est
l'école la République on est au cœur de
la vie de la cité offrir grâce à
scolaire par graviation scolaire les
activités les projets qui permettent de
vivre ensemble la rentrée s'est bien
passée sur trappes après les émeutes de
cet été il y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir
dans les écoles je vous le dire on est
extrêmement vigilant plus on a
d'excellents rapports avec les autres
services de l'État
non on n'a rien à dénoter de particulier
et heureusement merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau sur le plateau de ce 7 8actu du
vendredi on a évoqué la situation à
Trappes ces tensions mais il y a
d'autres communes aussi où les
incivilités se sont retrouvées se
retrouvent en Corse c'est le cas à
Guyancourt par exemple une pétition a
été lancée par des citoyens des
riverains qui dénoncent les incivilités
vécues dans leur quartier depuis cet été
Anthony Rey chez Jonathan Wilman
les nuisances dans le quartier de
Villaroy Guyancourt débute il y a deux
ans une vingtaine de jeunes s'amusent à
moto en bas des fenêtres des cailloux
sont jetés cet été les forces de l'ordre
doivent se déplacer à de nombreuses
reprises le problème c'est qu'il y a pas
de dialogue possible c'est que dès qu'on
demande gentiment d'avoir un petit lance
ou qu'il puisse un peu parler moins fort
ou pas circuler avec leur scooter c'est
on se fait agresser en fait verbalement
c'est à dire que moi je sors de chez moi
on me demande de sortir et puis de
régler ça au point dans la nuit du 13 au
14 juillet une dizaine de véhicules
aurait été vandalisés des poubelles
incendiées excéder certains habitants du
quartier lancent une pétition pour faire
réagir les pouvoirs publics munis de 178
signatures ils sont reçus par le maire
de Guyancourt le maire a pris contact
avec la commissaire de Guyancourt pour
voir un petit peu justement augmenter
la présence de la police nationale comme
la présence de la police municipale sur
le quartier et les les habitants l'ont
vu et nous l'ont dit
malgré cette réaction certains habitants
ont déménagé ou pensent à le faire les
auteurs de la pétition ont été reçus ce
jeudi par le maire pour faire un point
sur la situation ces derniers jours le
quartier de Villaroy semble s'être calmé
et puis ça je tiens que mardi prochain
alors du nouveau de rendez-vous de la
rédaction le 7 8 sociétés à 18h30
Catherine zolato organisera un débat sur
ces notions de civisme et de citoyenneté
et autour des incivilités également nous
allons poursuivre encore un peu ce
journal du vendredi avec un point
urbanisme pour conclure 80 000 véhicules
qui traversent chaque jour trappe via la
nationale 10 qui coupe tout simplement
la communion 2 un plateau de 400 mètres
de long va enfin pouvoir être réalisé
grâce à un coup de pouce de l'État
Catherine zelato pour les précisions
une lettre très attendue celle du
ministre des Transports qui confirment
sa volonté de couverture de la nationale
10 à Trappes et selon ces mots d'avancer
rapidement sur le dossier une
arlaisienne sur le point d'aboutir et
forcément le sourire chez le principal
intéressé le maire Guy Malandain depuis
2009 ce projet est bloqué pour parce que
des personnes je n'aimerais pas on n'est
pas là pour ça
avait décidé de faire passer l'autoroute
à 12 sur la ruralis à travers la ville
de Trappes mais aussi à travers les
villes qui suivent jusque jusqu'aux
Essarts-le-Roi et donc au changement de
gouvernement c'est comme ça j'y peux
rien et les autres avaient qu'à prendre
leur décision autrement nous avons
recommencé à travailler à discuter à
dialoguer à la fois au niveau politique
et à la fois au niveau technique le
projet présenté et conforme à celui de
2009 il s'agit d'une couverture
partielle de la nationale sur une
longueur de 400 mètres entre la mairie
et la station BP avec la création de
deux ronds-points entre le début et la
fin de l'opération autre projet le long
de cette nationale 10 pour créer une
cohésion urbaine trois aménagements
surface le premier au niveau de la
mairie un large plateau urbain le second
pour raccorder la rue Pierre Sémard et
la cour de la Corderie et le troisième
pour relier les rues Montfort et Carnot
le projet global enfouissement et
plateau urbain est estimé à 100 millions
d'euros financé par la Ville à hauteur
de 10 millions la casqui pour 15
millions et le reste entre région
conseil général et état de la part de la
ville bon de la Communauté
d'agglomération du département et de la
région les ce sont des crédits fléchés
des engagements signés et y compris dans
au sein de la convention de rénovation
urbaine le ministre s'est engagé et donc
l'état s'est engagé si tous suit son
cours l'enquête publique pourrait avoir
lieu fin 2014 pour un début de travaux
en 2015 et une livraison en 2018 la
nationale 10 ce sont chaque jour 80 000
véhicules ce sera alors une nouvelle
page de la ville à écrire
fin de cette édition du vendredi je vous
retrouve lundi pour l'information locale
n'oubliez pas également sur tvfils 78 le
7 8 le week-end complet sur vos loisirs
avec Anthony Rech 18h30 19h30 et 23h du
vendredi au dimanche excellente soirée